ah what's going on get it low yeah let's
talk about this set this apartment set
apartment but it's sort of interview
space but about all the things that you
love an etch-a-sketch machine beeps man
gumball machine you can't get clearance
for the things you actually like and I
know about clearances obviously well I
want to Batman why don't you make your
set of Batcave the thing one of the
things I don't like about Batman yes
mm-hmm
I don't like the Batcave as well I have
no idea is it too chewy can I tell you
something I don't like movies where
people look like they're cold right and
I don't like movies where people are
hungry the whole time that's why I
didn't see The Hunger Games on me no
they get their training lengthy no
they're fighting each other for like way
my my one remaining meal you are pretty
leg man green you are a interview show
hosting you just judge the book by its
cover just just identity by its side
Hunger Games
I don't watch Westminster Abbey because
it sounds like they're hung Downton
Abbey but gravity in this place here's
what's crazy is they'll leave that
moment in and this show is supposed to
make me look good but I have no control
over that ever I kind of feel like I
would like the Adam West Batcave a lot
the Adam wants Batman had the highest
quality of life
Oh a hundred percent it seemed like a
rich guy who just sometimes dressed up
in costume it did seem like they were
even - they did disguise his voice it
was a very distinctive voice yeah
especially for mature disguises balinese
Hill hung out with the same group of
rats so that's a very
letting things no one invited sounds
like out of West here we go this is a
well not see we've gone to visit a hot
seat chocolate or vanilla vanilla
what's your black people are white
people